so it's funny because you and i were
joking about this before
mike that when i was in your office
saying i'm going to
run for president um like i joked that i
was like the cryptocurrency of
presidential candidates because it was
like the thing that like you know some
people didn't see value in and then it
ended up
you know doing something so when did you
first
find out or hear about cryptocurrency
and then what was it that spurred you to
make like a significant investment that
now
has in my opinion just you you
single-handedly helped change the
trajectory
and history of what cryptocurrencies are
and how they're perceived
but like do you remember the first time
someone came to you
so a buddy called me up and he said dude
have you heard of bitcoin i said i said
do me a favor and look into it and so i
googled it i
asked some guys on my desk and it took
me about an hour to realize
it's going to go higher it was trading
this was 2013 it was trading at 95
and there were lots of reasons i thought
it would go higher
it resonated with libertarians
we were in 2012 the european financial
crisis coming off the back of the great
financial crisis
and there was all this worriness
around quantitative easing right ben
bernanke was the central bank governor
and he was printing lots of money
and so lots of very smart people thought
we would have hyperinflation
uh they didn't know the tea party was
coming uh
and so there was this
world that worried about inflation these
libertarians that didn't bought by the
government
there were these cypher punks that
wanted to live off the grid so there's
these constituencies
that wanted to participate in this kind
of new technology
which was really cool technology
and you could boil it down to one simple
sentence it was the first
digital signature you could encounter
fit and because of that
we could have digital money for the
first time before that
i would just be like yank sent me a yang
dollar i'm going to make 5 000 of them
and send them around right but this
blockchain
thing satoshi's white paper thing said
if i send you a yang dollar it's only
the yang dollar
and that concept i was like that's
really freaking cool
and so we this new technology and all
these constituents plus the chinese were
buying i was like it's going to go up so
i bought it originally as a speculative
asset thinking
i'm a speculator and i'll be smart now i
bought a lot of it
partly because i had a whole lot of
[ __ ] money you know
so when you're worth 800 million dollars
to buy 3 million
is it's a bet but it's you know less
than one percent of your net worth
sure what took courage was
to talk about it publicly to say
i actually think this is a really
interesting technology
and i didn't do it overnight i was
actually
kind of thrust onto the stage i
was written about in the ft because
there were some
reporters at a conference like that
where there was i didn't think there was
press and i was waxing on about this
and then i started getting i started
getting asked to speak at the oxford
union on tv
so i had to do more homework because i
didn't want to look like an idiot and so
as i dug in and try to understand
and i'm not a computer science guy it
was complicated computer science
but really understand the essence and
meet the people
i realized that this was more than a
financial trick that this was a social
revolution
and it was a political revolution it was
a revolution that said
we don't trust the center we think the
world is being built unfairly
we want more transparency we want a more
egalitarian framework
uh and we want to you know we're leery
of governments we're leary of
jp morgan where they're called the rent
takers and so it had a
revolutionary spirit spirit that
resonated with me
and after i left fortress or it left me
uh
and i dug in i really understood that
this was a
gen z and millennial middle finger
to the system that they somehow
intuitively knew that the baby boomers
were spending all the money uh
that grandpa's third hip operation was
worth more than
investing in education for the
generation that hasn't been born
and that we were blowing up deficits and
so
people like well why is all the young
kids buying it the young
this this is the social currency of gen
z and the millennials
and they might not even be conscious of
it but
because the baby boomers have screwed
the planet up
and now guys like you are trying to
figure out how do we
how do we fix it we need more leadership
to try to fix it
but this was a movement of young people
uh
that want more transparency that one
something that's more fair
and so that resonated with my political
ideals and so because i didn't think i'd
ever go back to work
it's running a family office is work but
it's really nice work
you make sure pets people come they
shine your shoes
handsome you are you make a movie every
once in a while
you do things you invest in non-profits
like yeah it's beautiful
and so i remember telling my team i was
like guys
we've been sitting here for two years
getting our shoes shined we're now the
shoeshine boys
get on your knees and pull out the
grease and start shut because running a
customer business and
really trying to build something is is
client focused
and so i wasn't going to make that
decision lightly and i made it under
three
i said i need to be with young people
and
this is a young person's movement i need
to be learning something every day
and when you get into the venture world
i remember media from venture america
and i invested in a
escape room like the young energy around
adventure is fascinating
yeah because you learn every
conversation uh
and third i needed to feel like i had a
contribution to make
and i teased about being the oldest guy
in crypto but i did think there was a
contribution
to connect this crypto energy to
institutions
i mean you're one of the preeminent
bridge builders
and frankly in my mind like uh
stampers of legitimacy in
in many ways uh you know one
reason i connected with the
cryptocurrency community
uh when i was running for president and
i talked to you about this before
is i found that something like 98 of
cryptocurrency
investors endorsed uh
some version of universal basic income
and i i think that
one of the reasons for that overlap was
that if you invest in cryptocurrencies
you have a mindset of abundance of
optimism you think about the future and
how things can be better and you also
frankly like you know you see people
laboring in scarcity and you think huh
like maybe there's a better way because
you've seen something go from
in your case 95 to 50 000
like over a particular period of time
and then when you see people
uh you know and obviously people working
hard i mean like you know you and i
uh appreciate the value of hard work but
like the the overlap
i found between cryptocurrency investors
and folks that want to make things
uh better and more modern in terms of
how people's time gets spent like the
overlap is very very high
to understand cryptocurrencies at its
core you start thinking about new
economic
models yeah and like how would it work
why don't we use the old ball if it's
not working
and i remember there's a guy named dan
larimer
uh and i talked to him for hours about
ubi
and he had the most interesting way of
thinking about ubi
uh which was you know
why just because you're saudi arabian
born
you get all the oil resources just
randomly because you were lucky to be
born on saudi arabia so
like maybe we should share share the
world's resources
and that if you taxed
total wealth about three percent a year
and redistributed it
uh over time with a generation and a
half you're recycling total wealth and
his idea of redistributing it wasn't all
at once it was like listen if the five
of us go to an island
and we give everyone equal sums the most
commercial guy is gonna have all the
money in about 32 days
but if we leak out a little bit each day
if andrew yang's the shark the rest of
us realize
stay away from the shark after a few
bites
and so you know you can literally
because of the
technology of cryptocurrency create a
system that
pays people by the hour wow but
think about think about government you
know
you know government transfer payments
you could literally have them
being delivered by the minute wow and so
i keep thinking
there's a we've got a world that's so
disjointed the rich poor gap is as wide
as it's ever been in history
i gave a speech in 06 that said the risk
per gap is so wide
it's going to end in revolution that was
15 years ago
and it's so much worse it skyrocketed
since then yeah and so we need
some redistribution but government has
not been a great
way to redistribute it's not efficient
it's bureaucratic
and so you can see a system of
redistribution directly
wow to wallet you know on some algorithm
that everyone kind of agreed to or the
politics agreed to uh and so
it draws crypto nerds in
because crypto nerds are about how do we
use this technology
to start reimagining things and i think
you're right abundance is a big part of
it
uh but it's also how do we reimagine
social policy
even that exchange where you highlighted
some of the possibilities
using the blockchain is incredible
i mean no wonder you talked to dad for
hours because that that'd be fascinating
i mean
that like there the need for new
economic models is so clear
uh and i think the cryptocurrency
community is
is light years ahead of a lot of us in
in large part because
most human beings operate in a mindset
of resource scarcity
it's kind of hardwired into us you know
it's biological they also
operate with the same mistake i made
when you said you want to be president
with a presupposition of they know what
that means
i know what a president is supposed to
have gone through therefore
if he doesn't pick the box i short
circuit i might learn a great lesson
with your success i'm saying like wait a
minute so in crypto it's the same thing
we're operating
most people say these are the economic
tools i'm allowed to think about
and the other guys are like no no we can
make new tools
right and so it's a really interesting
you know analogy of opening up
your mind and opening up the toolkit
[Music]
you